right this is the wheelchair this needs
charged up every night Susan Donnelly's
livelihood depends on electricity this
fridge in her bedroom stores her
antibody injections and her wheelchair
and nebulizer need to be plugged in each
night
turning any of it off is not an option
so she sacrifices what others take for
granted
I can't afford to buy food I've got
bread there I've got biscuits
that's it so or I might have a bowl of
cereal for my dinner she's been told the
energy price cap will stop her bill from
rising but nothing is bringing it down
I'm putting everything into my energy
bills
I've got nothing I've got 77 pence in my
bank
and I've gone past my overdraft limit
and there is nothing I can do about it I
can't physically put money in that I
haven't got for some people it's hoped
this will help from this month the
regulator off gems cap has fallen from
over 3 000 pounds to
2074. it means households will see their
bills full by an average of 426 pounds a
year
those that use more will pay more but
bills will still be more than double
what they were before the crisis this
will be the second year of excessive
price uh Rises people's debt will
increase people's cutting back to try
and avoid debt will increase as well
there is no end in sight cutting down
isn't an option for people like Susan I
don't know what else to do the
government told us this cap marked a
major Milestone which follows wholesale
Energy prices Falling by two-thirds from
their winter Peak but said they do want
to see prices even lower this limits by
the regulator will help when every penny
counts but many don't have a penny left
to count Ash Sky News in East London